the first thing so was there weren't
many surprises in it because the
government actually wanted to do the
opposite to what Liz truss and quasi
quattang had done and as you said Pitch
roll this lay the ground so there wasn't
any surprises that would unnerve or
Ripple the markets or unnerved voters or
indeed uh conservative MPS that's the
first night it was kind of as expected
apart from as you said a couple of
little rabbits in terms of a bit more uh
spending for schools and a bit more for
hospitals in the next two years but the
big pitch let's go back to the big pitch
from what's really happening in people's
lives and households because that
actually despite all the rhetoric of
this being reasonable and fair that's
where it's going to hit people the first
thing to say is it was indeed 55 billion
of tax Rises and spending cuts but what
the government has done and I've just
got the score card this is where you see
all the numbers of how it all actually
adds up so uh Jeremy Hunt spins it in a
certain way and then you see the numbers
and it tells you what's really going on
in terms of the spending cuts they have
been completely
backloaded to the next Parliament
politically why because the government
can look like it is consolidating at the
public finances but the pain of those
spending cuts will not be felt
potentially by this government given
that they might not be in power post
2025 of the 30 billion of spending cuts
the government have announced if I find
it 21 billion of them end up in 2027 to
28 so you can see exactly what's
happening in terms of the government
back loading that pain causing
potentially a labor government the
difficulties of taking those decisions
on tax and spend if you go back to the
taxation that we are seeing 24 billion
as we thought was 24.7 billion of total
tax decisions and that has been weighted
in part onto business you've got about 6
billion Ian coming in from those energy
levees you've got this freezing of Ni
employers contributions that brings the
treasury in 5 billion bahts for all of
us freezing income tax threshold drags
millions of people into higher bans it
affects everyone in the country that
plays income tax and by 2027 that is
Raising 6.8 billion from for the
treasury and when you look at in terms
of what they've done for spending in in
the short term in this Parliament yes
they've kept the spending envelope from
March
2022 that's about three percent of
spending growth but if you put that
against what inflations are that's a big
spending squeeze on schools and
hospitals and unprotected budgets which
is why perhaps the chancellors decided
to put a bit more money in
um but there is going to be a spending
squeeze there's going to have to be
efficiency savings and that has a
knock-on effect for public sector pay so
in terms of how this affects households
you can have income tax Rises for
everyone you're going to have public
sector pay being squeezed and just in
terms of how these decisions are hitting
households the obr report and this is
from Paul Johnson from the ifs digging
this out not me I should say he's
pointing out that real household
disposable income per person is going to
fall by more than seven percent over the
next two years it's the biggest fall on
record it will be taking household
incomes down to 2013 levels energy bills
are going to go up to 3 000 pounds April
2023 a typical household uh paying that
so I think politically what Jeremy Hunt
has tried to do here is take the
conservative party back onto the center
ground acknowledging that he needs to or
wants to protect NHS and education
budgets things that matter very much to
the public uh giving pensioners that
inflation lift giving benefits that
inflation lift giving more support to
households more vulnerable households on
energy bills so that's the nod to
compassion and fairness in the budget
but in reality
what they are dealing with if you have
to make a decision you have to have 55
billion of financial consolidation it's
massive and it's going to be painful and
it's going to be felt by households up
and down the country